chers amis vous venez de terminer vos
travaux aujourd'hui dans votre
département de réflexion sur l'avenir de
nos collectivités locales dans tous les
départements de france et d'outre-mer un
travail identique a été fait nous allons
nous baser dessus au niveau des
sénateurs de droite du centre et des
indépendants pour bâtir une réflexion et
être le garant des propositions que vous
avez fait vous pouvez être certain que
nous nous battrons pour défendre vos
idées pour défendre nos idées au
parlement nous sommes dans une période
extrêmement importantes ou des
propositions sont faites par la majorité
qui parfois peuvent vous inquiétez
peuvent nous inquiéter nous sommes là
pour être dans la vigilance la plus
extrême mais aussi pour faire des
propositions
et pour être ouvert à toutes les idées
que vous avez émises pendant les
réflexions de cette journée